[Music]
[Music]
i'm going to be giving a live demo today
of node.js and javascript don't think
that node.js is the only thing you're
allowed to use with microservices that
is definitely not the case we're going
to be using docker and docker allows you
to host almost any language or or
runtime that you want you can use python
ruby um
go
other there's this rust maybe there's
heaps of languages that you can use
i like to use node.js with either
javascript or typescript mostly
typescript these days
let me explain why
to start with javascript while it's not
the world's best programming language
i'll concede that i do believe it's the
world's most practical language you can
do almost anything with javascript using
node.js means we can go truly full stack
it means we can go anywhere in our tech
stack without changing language so
we can work on the front end in
javascript we can work on the back end
in javascript and so on i personally use
javascript and typescript across my
whole stack back ends front ends mobile
applications and more node.js for its
part was made for this it was made for
building distributed applications
the name node actually implies that
node.js is intended to be a node in a
network-based application
so node is network orientated and it
includes all the fundamental building
blocks that we need for creating network
applications the fact that node.js was
built for this kind of thing
makes building microservices with
node.js particularly easy and i hope
that's going to come across to you
in the live demo where i'm going to show
you how easy it is to get started
passing data between micro services is
easy as well with node.js and that's
because the de facto standard for
communication between services on the
internet is json
and that's something that's built into
javascript and indeed it was born from
javascript now you've also probably
noticed that node.js has a huge
community i mean that can be
overwhelming for newcomers you know
seeing that there is so much stuff out
there but just keep this in mind you
know there are a lot of tools libraries
tutorials other resources that's a lot
of things to help you get started and to
get you the help that you need when
you're learning and more importantly the
community is so huge um so there are
lots of people that you can lean on when
you need help and you know reach out to
us where some of us are really helpful
at least now i think there's a bunch of
other benefits to working with
javascript and i'm not going to go into
those now hopefully i've made my case
for node.js this is a quick summary of
the basic needs of a microservice a
typically a microservice needs some way
to communicate with other microservices
and possibly the outside world
so it's got a bunch of communication
requirements
it also needs to be able to store
persistent data so that's either data in
a database or files in file storage or
some other kind of storage
today we're going to keep things really
simple and we're just going to look at a
once one simple micro service and we're
just going to give it some really basic
communication facilities so we're not
going to go too far with this today
and we're not going to explore all these
things but but i do explore all these
things in my book bootstrapping
microservices in quite some detail
we'll come back to that in a moment it's
a good time to to start your prayers to
the demo gods that this all works out
for me today now i'm using windows 11
now it doesn't matter what operating
system you use this should everything i
show you should be the same
so you can do this under mac os you can
do this under linux it shouldn't make
much of a difference i have no js
installed already
version 16 13 1
so
if you need to install node.js it's
pretty simple to install it on all the
major platforms
just visit the node.js website
obviously i also have docker because i'm
going to be building a docker image out
of this
at the end i am running docker 2010 12.
so to get docker i advise if you're on
windows or mac os
install docker desktop it's really it's
really awesome it's a little bit more
difficult to get working on windows than
on mac
and there is no docker desktop for linux
as far as i can tell
but you can also install docker kind of
in a more manual way on linux
if you if that's what you're using i'm
going to make from scratch
a really simple node.js application that
would could be uh the basis of a new
microservice so i'm going to start by
creating a new directory
called today um if you're on mac os
obviously you'll be using or linux you'd
be using maker not md that's a that's a
windows command
now to create uh like a starb
node.js program we use
npm init dash y so npm is the nodejs
package manager it's what we use
normally for installing and uninstalling
packages from the online node.js
package repository
npm and knit will basically create like
a new kind of
project for us or a new package
description
using the dash y command will just
default it so it's going to default
to uh so i don't have to type anything
in basically if you don't use dash y
it's interactive and you have to do a
bit of typing so it just gives you this
kind of basic setup
and if we look in the directory here
you can cut the package file
or if you're wondering why i'm using
linux commands on windows it's because i
have i think it's because i have git for
windows installed which comes with a
bunch of useful linux commands so it
makes uh using windows a lot more like
using mac os or linux anyway so i've
just printed out the contents of the
package file there so this is the the
package file for node.js is the file
that kind of manages the metadata for
the projects and tracks all the packages
and dependencies that we have installed
let's create some code before i get to
that next bit anyway i'm going to open
visual studio code from this directory
at this point i'm basically just going
to start by creating a hello world
program so nothing nothing too exciting
here's my project open you can see the
package file
we can open the package file and have a
look at what's in there
actually i don't know i don't want to
create a file i want to create a
folder
so normally i have a src folder that
contains my source code
the typical um
kind of main file for a node.js project
is called index.js sometimes people call
it main.js or server.js or something
like that
it's fairly common to call it index.js
that's what i like to call it i'm just
going to put a console log in here
and just do a hello world
and now we're going to switch back to my
terminal and run that
so we're starting pretty basic uh so i'm
running node i'm running node but i'm
going to run i give it a file to run
index.js we get our hello world that's
our starting point now typically at this
point
i've got some code i've got a starting
point
it's not much um this is where i might
do like a git init to create a git
repository and then every subsequent
change i do a git commit um and and to
save in my in my source control the
results of my coding
i'm not going to worry about git today
that's just adding unnecessary
complexity so let's just pretend that
normally i would do that if i was making
a micro service what do i want to do to
turn this hello world program into a
very very basic micro service i need
these communication tools so
communication to be able to kind of talk
to other micro services or the outside
world or the ability to kind of accept
incoming messages from other micro
services as i said earlier on node.js
contains everything that we need to do
network-based programming the only
problem is is the node.js apis as they
are as they come
are very low level and a bit complicated
and tricky so most people don't use them
most people install like an a package
from the npm
from the node package repository in
order to make you know this kind of
thing a little bit simpler so that's
what i'm going to do today as well and
the first package i'm going to install
is express so express is the kind of de
facto standard
framework for building a rest api or a
web server in node.js so there's plenty
of other options like
i'm using happy on one project i'm using
nesjs on another project i'm working on
express just seems to be the most common
and standard one and actually most of my
projects i've ever done have been on
express so i'm exploring other options
at the moment but the express is still
great and it's still a uh it's still i
think it's a de facto standard for
node.js so i'm just going to install
that
so this is going to allow us to handle
incoming http requests from other
microservices and possibly from from
external services as well
so once i've installed that and i'll go
back to visual studio code you can see
here in the package file that i've got a
dependency now so it's tracked that
dependency so
if i want to share this project with
someone else
they just take a copy of it or they take
a clone of my repository and they do an
npm install and they'll automatically
get all of the all of the dependencies
that i've installed for that project
okay so what are we going to do with
express well i'm going to cheat
i'm going to actually go to the
the express documentation and copy an
example from there which i've got
open here so this is just
expressjs.com
i've just drilled into the hello world
example you know this is basically all i
need and i'm not going to do too much
more than this
so
rather than typing on all this code i'm
just going to copy that in
so it's a nice a nice uh way to get
started
i just i like semicolons i can't i can't
read go without semicolons
and i'm also going to run the visual
studio code formatter so just get this
in my standard formatting style
how nice does that look now
so this is just a simple program
requires in the express library creates
an express application it's hard coded
to run on local port 3000
we've got a single http route handler
here that sends hello world back to the
browser and we're listening we're
starting the application by listening
for incoming http requests now if it
starts up correctly we should see this
message uh printed example app listening
on port 3000
so let's start that
at the moment i might try running my
terminal
and my
code side by side
so to run this
i run indexed
yep my index.js
and i should have a
web server listening on port 3000
let's have a quick look at that
so let's look at localhost yup that's it
localized3000
and if you can see that it's pretty
small let's zoom in hello world
so not terribly exciting yet but we're
getting there we're getting there
now one thing i want to do is um you can
see i'm i'm changing code i'm editing
code every time i do that i've got i've
got to stop the web server i've got to
start it again
that's a little bit of a pain so i want
to kind of i want to make this process a
little bit faster i want to have
my web service automatically reload what
i call live reload every time i edit my
code
now before i do that i just want to
implement in in the script section here
of the package.json
i want to implement a start script i'll
show you what this does in a moment but
my start script is going to run node
source
index.js
so this is just what we are doing then
it's nothing different except now that
i've implemented that start script i can
use the npm convention
npm start to start it
now the reason this is important is
because it makes your project follow
conventions so
typically
whatever node.js project you get from
your colleague or from some random open
source person on the internet
if you run npm start that's what's going
to start it and it doesn't matter
whether you've got this index.js or
whether you've called it main.js or you
know like it'll be set up here to start
whatever the file is and possibly also
if it requires command line arguments um
[Music]
you know what it whatever it needs will
automatically
be configured to work on npm start so
it's just set up for nice convenient and
whatever project you're working on
whatever micro service you're changing
to and you might be working on you know
a bunch of different micro services
which whichever one you go to
you just have to remember npn start will
start it
so that's a nice convention
now how i'm going to make this work with
the live reload is i'm going to install
nodemon
so i'm saving that as a dev dependency
you can see here i've used save dev
so that means it's not a production
dependency this dependency
is only for for use in development and
what nodemon does is it's like a drop-in
replacement for node except it's going
to watch my code files and when my code
files change it's automatically going to
reload them so you can see here it's
added a dev dependency of nodemon
now when you install this for production
uh on when you want to run this on your
production server you're only going to
install these production dependencies
here so
you don't you don't need nodemon in
production
now i'm going to update my
my scripts here to include a new one and
this is my this is not a node.js
convention it's more my personal
convention
some other people use this or a similar
convention i'm going to run nodemon and
i'm going to give it that javascript
file so this time instead of running
node like we normally do in production
i'm going to run nodemon so this is this
is for running in development
and uh or one thing i have to add here
if you want to run this under docker i
think you've got to add legacy watch so
unfortunately the the file system
watching doesn't doesn't work out of the
box and it has to poll this puts it in
polling mode you only need this if
you're going to eventually run this
project under docker like we're going to
do
so now i can run npm or i've got to use
npm run i've got to use the full sort of
convention here because it's not a
node.js convention
npm run start dev
now i should have an automatically
reloading server
so let's
say you can see here what what node 1 is
doing is it's saying it's watching for
extensions you know js is the important
one here if it's if it sees a change in
a javascript file it's automatically
going to reload
and it's also run our code so you can
see here it's run our code under node
and our
web server is running but i could put
code here i could say
something like
now i'm going to save this file
and you can see here
that node 1 has said restarting due to
changes so it's and it's starting it
again and this time it's printed that
message so this is a nice way of working
where you can actually just keep coding
and you don't have to kind of rerun your
code it automatically does that for you
okay so let's let's do a little bit more
work on our
server here so you can sort of get an
idea of what we or what we need
one thing we need is to be able to
accept messages incoming from other
micro services so let's pretend that
we've got one called
let's make this a to-do application i
know that's very cliche but it does it
does fit in with the data that i'm going
to show you in a moment
let's say we if we get to do's
so in this case this is like a query
from another microservice
and pretend this is the to do's micro
service
that is responsible for getting the
to-do's from somewhere and returning
them for the other micro services so
we're getting a list of to-do's that's
sort of what the purpose of this is um
so this is like a query it could also be
an action like it could be like um
we could use a post a http post to add a
to-do to the database
or we use a get to retrieve a list of
to-do's or we have a get for maybe a
single to do the return uh the reason
i'm doing to-do's um is because there's
this great website called uh jason
placeholder it's great for experimenting
with working with rest apis and it's
just it's just a rest ap online it gives
you some examples using fetch i'm not
going to use fetch i'm going to use
axios in a moment instead of fetch
but it's got a whole bunch of different
endpoints i'm going to use the to do's
endpoint which you can look at by
clicking on it
and so this is the kind of data that i'm
going to be working with that's just
available online
for anyone to work with i've got an
endpoint here i'm just going to just
test test that i can do this
so that's going to restart my web page
or restart my web server
i i have to manually reload my web page
to viewer
but that's something you can deal with
as well in fact i've got a blog post and
a talk coming up on how to do live
reload everywhere in the browser uh in
docker uh
and uh so so stay tuned for that if you
like this technique of of live reload
if i can test this here
oops
got to add some parameters here and the
error message there is telling me that
let's just refresh the browser
yep to do so that's sort of my
placeholder for where i'm going to
actually get the to-do's and return them
okay so what am i doing oh yeah i've got
to install axios
so
like i said um node.js has everything
you need to do network operations but
it's pretty low level and pretty clunky
to use
but you can use it and you can kind of
set it up however you want but most
times we use these higher level
libraries that makes our lives easier
one such library and
uh kind of the the de facto standard for
making rest api requests
is called axios so you might have heard
of that because it's pretty popular but
that just makes oops
gotta do that i forgot to do the install
command correctly
so axios will just make our lives a
little bit easier when we're making
requests
to other micro services just to make
this move a little bit
quicker i'm going to copy some code that
i've got on my cheat sheet here so let's
just uh
import axios
so we're just importing the axios module
there so we can use it
except i'll just type this in and i'll
copy i have to copy the url because it's
kind of long
so i'm going to do a http get request
using axios
now i can
let me see if i can find the thing i'm
looking for here
this is this is the actual if i go into
this to do this here
this is like literally what i want i'm
just copying what i've from the address
bar here i'm just copying that
and i'm gonna i'm gonna send my get
request at that
now let's just do that first
and then so we'll turn up uh like a
handler on a promise handler on here to
get the response
and i'm just the first thing i want to
do is just print the response to see
what happens
i'm going to print the data in the
response
and then uh
there could be an error there could be
an area there and if i don't have a
catch handler i might miss that error so
i'm just just to make sure you know like
like if i put it like a plate like a
typo here or something like that that
would cause an error probably
and i might not be able to see that if i
didn't have the catch but let's um
log the error
so just so i can make that error visible
just in case there is a problem
um
i'm just going to send something back
anyway i'll change that in just a moment
so i've got to restart this now after
i've installed axios and what i'm
looking for here is i should be able to
kind of hit this to-do's endpoint in the
browser so by the way i'm just testing
from the browser here
but um there are other ways to test rest
apis um
you might have heard of postman that's a
really popular one um but in in vs code
rest client there's a there's a really
good one called sorry in visual studio
code there's a really good plugin paul
vs code oh sorry
vs rest client a vs rest client google
that that's that's a really good way um
because um this will only get you so far
doing it in the browser will only get
you so far it works for us today so i'm
just gonna oh where's my example here we
go
i'm just gonna refresh this uh
browser here and we should see on the
side here my on the left hand side my
console log
there we go so you can see here a lot of
to-do items have been printed out
and it's returned the one two three
string that i'd that i'd coded in there
now what we want to do
is we just want to
send jason back
so we're responding with jason and to
keep it simple i'm just going to return
all the data
now
you know this is going to do
actually before i before i run this just
for completeness
if there is an error
i don't want to just leave the browser
hanging i want to send a status code of
you know something something wrong in
the server status code 500 which is
which is a standard that's part of the
standard http status codes
so i'll go back to here now when i
refresh this you should see
two zoomed in let's zoom out
but here you can see there's a massive
list of to-do's been returned in json
format so you just have to pretend here
that instead of this being in the
browser that another micro service is
making this request to get the list of
to do's from the to do service and it's
getting back this list of data
now normally it wouldn't look this nice
but i've got it i've got a plug in here
that i think is just called you know
jase the
json plug-in or something like that um
that formats it really nicely in the
browser let's look at what else you
could do with this system so
um you would also want maybe
a
http post to to-do's
and
you would say that here this is where
maybe a to-do gets added
and you can have as many of these
handlers as you want to handle incoming
messages or query requests from other
micro services
i'm not going to worry about filling
that out um so you can imagine that you
know uh
and in this case here we're actually
like this is this simulates forwarding a
request to another micro service in this
case because i don't have another micro
services i i've only created the first
microservice so there can't be another
micro service yet
but
just imagine that this is talking to
another micro service but in in reality
it's talking to an outside service an
external
an external website
but this could also be you know
something like you know
do a database query
and return to-do's from database so you
know that that is what this might
actually do instead but i'm going to
leave it as is because i want to
demonstrate this in docker now and i and
i don't want to break my code
i'm going to put it back to the way it
was
i'm just going to do a quick test to
make sure that that is working so when i
put it in docker
it's gonna be all good
so there's not much here i mean this is
like 25 lines of code right
but but i'm sure you'll agree that this
is a simple effective me way of getting
started on building a micro service
there's much more you can add to this
we'll talk about that in a moment about
you know what what one of the more
advanced aspects of of micro services
but you know believe it or not though
this this simple bit of code this is
just simply a great starting point for a
microservice let's dockerize this
you